[Música]
hablamos como lo estamos adelantando de
la variante o micro dónde el coronavirus
y por la que reinó unido- entonces ya
convocó una reunión de urgencia a los
ministros de salud del g7 para así
abordar los riesgos y los problemas que
representa esta variante el país
confirmó que ya detectó hasta ahora tres
contagios por este tipo todos conectados
con viajes desde el sur de áfrica e
investiga otros posibles contactos
mientras tanto hoy la organización
mundial de la salud que celebra una
asamblea extraordinaria en la que los
países miembros negocian un tratado en
respuesta para respuestas de futuras
pandemias con el objetivo de no repetir
los errores advirtió que omicron
representa un muy alto riesgo y para
ello quiero saludar entonces a maría
fernanda gutiérrez bióloga de la
universidad javeriana en la ciudad de
bogotá colombia maría fernanda gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo a
maric y le pregunto los riesgos que
representa esta nueva variante de kobe
19 bueno esta nueva variante está en
estudio
se apareció más o menos la tenemos
reportadas ya hace un poco más de un mes
pero todavía no tenemos información
suficiente yo quiero recordar lo que ha
pasado con las variantes anteriores
desde que empezó con la primera variante
y pnv la alfa empezamos a especular a
decir bueno viene una crisis porque
viene una variante que va a ser y
enumerábamos todas las cosas que iba a
ser generalmente malas y así nos fue
pasando con las otras variantes llegamos
a la delta y la situación fue muy
copiada a la alfa decir repetimos lo
mismo es una variante mucho más agresiva
es una variante más más y en este
momento estamos repitiendo otra vez
volvemos a decir es una variante más sin
tener suficiente información la poca
información que tenemos nos dice que no
es muy distinta a la delta
es decir por ahora sabemos que responde
a las pruebas de diagnóstico que es muy
importante porque la prueba de
diagnóstico que nos va a ayudar a ver
pues su presencia entonces la prueba de
pcr
sirve funciona con esta variante en las
vacunas también funcionan con esta
variante entonces eso nos lleva a tener
pues un poco de tranquilidad pensando
que por lo menos podemos continuar por
el camino obviamente siempre vamos a
necesitar mejoras y estas las están
haciendo ya están buscando todas las
alternativas para mejorar inclusive en
las casas farmacéuticas la vacuna para
que he estado por la cura seguramente
esta variante o mica o sea digamos que
por ahora entonces no hay momento no hay
que estar preocupados no es momento de
alarmarse tampoco esperar a los estudios
para ver qué arroja esta variante
entonces y por qué viene la preocupación
de la mamá s porque digamos que fue
casualidad entonces que la ms será de
emergencia para hablar para abordar
futuras pandemias con la aparición de
esta nueva variante omicron y además
porque ella y algunos países han
prohibido los viajes al sur de áfrica en
la mesa dijo un momento no no sabemos
todavía no hay necesidad de todavía
parar los vuelos si es por ahí es decir
no es no no es dejarla diciendo no nos
ha pasado nada no es una variante de
hecho las clasifican como éstas como
variantes de estos actos clasificadas
como variante de preocupación quiere
decir una variante que debemos ponerle
más
están más pendientes de ella porque es
que el virus en realidad muta con mucha
frecuencia pero no todas las mutaciones
generan unos cambios de comportamiento
de viral que llamen la atención entonces
uno empieza como en observación le
pueden decir variante de observación y
luego si entra al variante de
preocupación porque ya se considera que
es una variante que tiene una cosa que
se conoce como fitness mayor capacidad
de penetrar a la población y de
establecerse es muy probable que ésta
empiece a tomar una posición importante
de hecho ahorita colombia está casi que
en el 80 o 90 por ciento con la variante
delta nada de raro tiene que empieza a
entrar la variante omicron hemos sabido
siempre que desafortunadamente va a ser
para los no vacunados porque son los no
vacunados el grupo más sensible a ser
infectado entonces es probable que
empecemos a tener esta variante como
presente y con prevalencia es un poco
más altas de lo que hubiéramos deseado
pero yo no diría que no nos preocupemos
yo diría que estemos alerta en colombia
mientras mientras van pasando las cosas
mientras el gremio científico va
entendiendo un poco más tenemos que
aumentar completamente nuestras medidas
de control de bioseguridad el tapaboca
no lo podemos dejar la distancia social
no la podemos dejar pero sabemos que eso
funciona es decir sabemos que con esas
medidas podemos tener más o menos
controlada la cosa la vacunación
funciona entonces es muy importante
aumentar las tasas de vacunación
mientras pasa lo que esté pasando es
decir mientras esa variante se consolida
porque tienen mayor fitness puede entrar
más fácil pero no sabemos cómo se
comporta en países tropicales o en
ciertas condiciones medioambientales
maría fernanda y es que usted habla de
un aspecto muy importante vacunación
contra el hobbit 19 qué tanta
efectividad tienen las vacunas que
tenemos ahora en el mercado contra estas
variantes del virus igual sigue siendo
una buena medida de protección digamos
no sin duda alguna es es la medida de
protección la tenemos clara la
efectividad desde el principio no la
habían comentado derecho las casas
farmacéuticas van reportando mi vacuna
tiene una efectividad del 95 por ciento
y es muy importante tener claro ese 95
por ciento porque que quiere decir que
hay un 5 por ciento de personas que
formarse que se vacunen no logran quedar
protegidas ese 5% es normal son son
éxitos en biología uno no puede hablar
rojo y blanco decir en biografía y
rosados entonces tenemos un grupo de
personas que por más de que se vacunen
puede no quedar protegidas a eso le
podemos atribuir estos casos que son muy
muy mediáticos es que yo me vacuné pero
me enferme y además fulanitos enfermo y
se murió pero ya se había vacunado y dos
dosis es mal ya van a decir tres dosis
claro pero esas cosas pues en biología
hay hay en sus pequeños rangos en donde
hay gente que no queda vacuna
las casas farmacéuticas lo han dicho
todo el tiempo y otra cosa antes de que
me te rompa es que estos son los
reportes que salen de los estudios de
fase 3 las vacunas cuando salen al
mercado ya salen con estudios de fase 3
quiere decir que ya la han hecho a un
grupo grande de personas pero que el
comportamiento de la vacuna de todas
maneras cuando entra a la población y ya
deja de ser controlada la vacunación me
refiero por estudios controlados en fase
1 pasó de fase 3 hay unos grupos que le
llaman fase 4 y es cuando la vacuna sale
a al medio ya y en ese momento también
tiene un poquito de cambio entonces
puede cambiar y en ese momento la
eficacia de la vacuna puede ser un
poquito distinta pero eso lo estamos
viendo la cantidad cosas que estamos
aprendiendo al tiempo con la pandemia es
gigante maría fernanda hablamos de la
pandemia el fin de la pandemia para
cuando se hablaba de mediados del año
2022 cuán lejos o cuán cerca estamos de
que se acabe la pandemia decir pues ya
es algo endémico en algunos lugares esa
pregunta no se la vamos a contestar yo
creo que arriesgarse
no vale la pena porque nosotros no
sabemos mire yo yo creo que la ciencia
va haciendo su trabajo los medios van
haciendo su trabajo pero el virus
también va haciendo su trabajo y cada
uno lo está haciendo como lo sabe hacer
entonces el virus cómo va a comportarse
el virus pues no sabemos estamos viendo
que mientras más demore mohsén
vacunarnos y más focos de infección
fuertes tengamos mayor posibilidad de
mutación y si hay mutaciones es nos
vamos a demorar un poquito más entonces
lo que necesitamos definitivamente es
vacunar nos para evitar que para tener
un gran porcentaje la población y evitar
darle espacio al virus para que mute y
que si así pasemos de omicron a la
siguiente letra griega no sé cuál va a
ser pero no le contesto esa pregunta
bueno maría fernanda nos quedamos
entonces con la vacunación con las
medidas de bioseguridad
tapabocas no estar en en muchas
multitudes